après l'échec de la négociation
bilatérale entre américains et russes
sur le cren à genève washington veut
rassurer les européens excluent des
discussions sur ce dossier depuis deux
mois
nous ne prendrons pas de décision sur
l'ukraine sans l'ukraine sur l'europe
sans l'europe sur l'otan sans l'otan
emmanuel macron avait estimé il ya deux
ans que l'otan se trouvait en état de
mort cérébrale
c'est pourtant ironiquement par ce biais
là que les européens font leur retour à
la table des discussions
21 des 27 pays européens sont
représentés par un ambassadeur à
bruxelles lors de la réunion entre
l'otan et la russie ce mercredi
le président français y voient une
opportunité nous défendons une approche
européenne qui combine fermeté face à
toute menace d'agression et maintient
des canaux de dialogue afin de trouver
la voie d'un apaisement
paris à eux devraient ces derniers jours
à la remise en route du format normandie
ces négociations à quatre entre français
allemands russes et ukrainiens qui se
tiennent depuis 2014 committee en 2019
le quai d'orsay a envoyé des diplomates
à moscou et à kiev avec un certain
succès
le président ukrainien informé les
dirigeants du format ne m'ont dit qu'ils
étaient prêts à une nouvelle réunion
en attendant cette réunion qui selon
l'elysée pourrait avoir lieu d'ici la
fin du mois les ministres des affaires
étrangères et de la défense des 27 se
retrouvent ce mercredi soir non pas à
bruxelles comme habituellement mais à
brest en france pour deux jours de
rencontres dans le cadre de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
l'occasion de s'accorder sur une
démarche commune sur le dossier
ukrainien afin de peser davantage